foreign
chickens are basically the mascot of Cs
go but that doesn't mean they're not
annoying as hell 10 seconds left drops
has to hold on to his gun check him
blocking the door I've not seen that
before if that gets him killed oh my God
a chicken Block in the door just got
hops killed
just check in holes and lean up they're
gonna get the first head shot there
trying to hold the chicken yep the
chicken I'd have thrown him off
yeah
so what the [__] is this chicken where
is the blood going where is he going
[Music]
the she can beat me one kill bats still
trying to cross on the site he saw the
chicken winter just shot the chicken
that was moving